huh you are first again cat tiger
that was so weird
no Darkness under yo from Tyrone that's
awesome
and I know he does reactions to my my
stuff it's cool welcome welcome welcome
hello is it better now we had a problem
before it just kind of stuck oh no it's
frozen again
I know it's not frozen again okay
yeah I was frozen I guess it didn't say
I had a problem on my side which is
weird
it's my camera blurry no it looks fine
wait what is that on my screen on my
camera
like a big old smudge
hmm
Jeff likes Kpop what's up
hey Mr Anderson how's it going uh so
just so everyone's aware My Stream just
crashed like two minutes ago
um it might do it again I have zero idea
what oh you know what it's been
thunderstorming a lot
and I live on a mountain there's only
one internet provider out here it's
fiber which is nice but uh sometimes
it's uh you know
sometimes it's a little rough sometimes
a little rough
thanks Gregory Bush appreciate that uh
we're full of Harold Tom Holland bro who
would you like to play Centurion the MCU
I I honestly really think Henry Cavill
would be would be good somebody
I don't know how you'll tell me because
you're in chat somehow is it Henry
Cavill
or Henry Cavill I feel like when I say
it in videos I say it one way and then
I'll say it the other way and no matter
what everyone says I'm saying it wrong
it's kevl right
am I wrong
ah knicker bobber I think
I think he is going to show up in this
episode Jake Chris is not doing She-Hulk
uh because
his sister's internet
does not work anymore
they can he said they they could barely
watch Netflix so
uh they just bought a house and I
believe they move into it next week
so he might he might jump on for the
finales
and
started up again once they are in their
house and they have internet and
everything like that so
what am I looking at Mr Anderson
I don't know what link
you sent me it it just took me to
it just took me to YouTube's home page
that's all it did
uh Ezekiel I think some people are only
watching for digital yeah yeah
hold on I feel like uh
uh Jay die Jack it's not so I say live
on top of a mountain it's not like I'm
isolated alone like it's a big
neighborhood like there's thousands of
homes up here
um and there's like an outlet mall at
the bottom of it at the base of it Adobe
second headquarters is at the base of it
as well so it's like very populated like
it's a very populated place but I am
high and it's not like a ski mountain
right it's a it's a tiny little mountain
but I but yeah I uh
yeah I I live on a mountain
it's not like I live in a cabin or
anything like that and I like have to
you know hike through the snow to go
anywhere
uh much love Jake look much love Jake
yeah he should be back
uh did anybody tell me how to pronounce
it Mr Anderson I don't know why that
Link's it's not taking me uh
oh wait here we go
how do I how does
cattle that's how I've been saying it
and people still want to correct me
it's Wong in time long Earth
thanks Kyle I appreciate that it's
Cavill not Cavill
that's what I'm saying like help me but
I know I can't like the chat's not gonna
is my voice low guys
I saw one person say it
seems fine on my uh on my phone on my
YouTube app
guys I figured something out I figured
something out with the help of Greg over
the real rejects check this out hold on
um
look
we can I can see it now look I did it
we did it
but now stop because copyright also go
back to English not Korean
I am tired so if we're talking about my
voice being soft that's
I know you can't really see
but I did change like my studio just a
little bit
um I like shifted everything put some
new things in put some new Elgato stuff
in of course shout out to them they
always uh
they're the reason this looks so good
and
[Music]
um
Elgato has this new stand that I'm using
for my camera and a lot of people have
always been asking me like what the room
looks like and I can kind of do this now
thanks to this new stand
everyone wants to see rocket there's
rocket
and then more to the right oh
the cables are sticking it but there's
more over there if I had a better cable
if I had a better cable I would or a
longer cable because the cable is kind
of restricting it right now
but uh what is that what is that oh it's
my keyboard no what is oh it's my mouse
yeah the camera's at a different angle
because I just like it's really I can't
explain it like my desk wasn't like
lined up against the wall it was like
turned and now I push it up against the
wall so I have some more room and so I
could set up more like lights and stuff
so
I'm happy with how everything turned out
let's just go here this new stand is
really great I really like it
more rocking in the video so I'm gonna
get
another camera that just
that just has let's just like uh
um a view of rocket and I'll put it like
in the corner or something yeah
uh Diva Can we see high or scar by the
end of the show uh Team Gucci hi hello
um
I I wouldn't plan on that I I wouldn't
plan with that
I feel like you'll be let down I don't
think we'll see it um
have you heard that Halle Berry no
longer wants to play superheroes I mean
I didn't expect her to you know
show up at storm again I'm expecting a
new storm so
uh Tom Holland uh I actually was
thinking to do a video on that soon
about I know I mentioned it in
did I mention in today's video
about a soft reboot after Secret Wars
today's video yesterday's video
um
yeah I think
it's a possibility I should do
whereas before like
I didn't think it
I didn't think they'd do it and now I I
kind of feel like yeah maybe they will
do it maybe maybe we will I'm actually
thinking
like it it might be a good idea but it
might not be a good idea like I like the
idea of starting fresh but I don't like
the idea of erasing
what we already have you know so
uh how much longer till the episode
releases eight minutes
Jake you have a great night thanks for
stopping by I'll tell Chris you said hi
even though he is on a cruise right now
so even if he did have internet he would
not be streaming tonight
oh
okay for for my K-pop fans out there
blackpink
um a lot of people have been asking me
um to start like a K-pop Channel just
like the cosmic wonder where I do news
and stuff and reactions and reviews I've
officially done that
I've been keeping it a secret till I
posted a little bit of content on there
but now I have a little bit of content
on there so now I will give it to
everybody there you go
anyone who likes and I'll be talking
about like music in general as well not
just K-pop so if you like music if you
like K-pop you can check that out put
that link in there I'll shove it in
there a few more times
like I said I kept that quiet for a long
time
but Josh Wright thank you so much
appreciate that appreciate that I'm uh
I'm trying to work on you know getting
better at content so
hey Daniel watch glad you love kpop and
Marcus looks like uh you already know
appreciate that yeah go ahead and check
that link out
uh would you want Marvel to live action
or series of the Hulk and Agents of
Smash
probably a series
I'm
I'm hesitant to give
I'm hesitant to give some shows or to
like to say I want some
some character stories to be shows
because I think there's just
you know Cinema hits you differently
right like right now this is great I
love the live shows and everything like
that but when you go to the when you go
to the theater and you sit down and you
grab a drink and popcorn and I I get so
much snacks when I go to the movies like
like so much snacks like I I I I really
do like I get a soda a large soda a
bigger big popcorn
um I always get like like nachos or hot
dog or something and then I get candy
like I love the movies like everything
about the movies not only like the
actual movie itself but like the
experience as a whole that's why 2020
really was like it was it was a hit for
me like when some theaters closed I was
like no like
like I spent my childhood watching
movies so an interesting story real
quick my dad for like a long time when I
was young he he
I don't explain this but basically he
was you know in this really really big
company where the owner is like one of
my dad's best friends when he was alive
and I still talked to a billionaire like
his house is 50 million dollars it's a
castle it's insane so he worked with him
and they did credit card machines like
they sold them like when you process
them and stuff like that so my dad sold
those to like the largest theater chains
like ever so I went on the road with him
a lot and when he was doing business I
would just go in I would sit in theaters
and I would watch movies while he would
work right I'd just do them for free and
like sometimes he'd be you know working
for a really long time I'd see like
three movies in like one day and then
the next day I'd do it again
um and then my dad would like watch
movies with me too and that's how like I
kind of got into movies because I just
watched a ton of movies since I was like
since I was like seven years old and
then at home me and my dad we would
watch movies a lot too
so
yeah yeah Christian Santa you get it you
get it
you get it you get it
bunker VR if you take the S out of
cosmic wonderful comic Wonder
got you gotcha uh
thanks for that comment Bongo just so
you guys know like anybody asking for
shout out like I don't just do shout
outs like if I read your comment I will
say your name but I'm not gonna just be
and if you say something nice like you
know but I'm like if you go hey give me
a shout out I will ignore it just so you
guys know
um
I do think Daredevil is going to be in
this episode for for everybody asking
yes I do
uh can you do a countdown when you play
the show yes I do I do that um
uh Leon I would like to uh
both I'd like a I'd like a updated one
with like new characters that aren't in
the comic version but
also
I would like
it to kind of be the same because it's
pretty awesome
what did I do to my hair dude I honestly
don't know
like it was
sorry I meant to diet blue and I did
diet blue for kcon
and then I dyed it back Brown and then
it just faded to Gold whatever this is
so
hey Warren Go frost your tips with your
K-pop BS okay
I don't know anyone who still Frost
their tips that was very 90s
I feel like it was a 90s thing
I feel like it was not anything
it's it's Daredevil time I really hope
so
the episode's gonna drop in two minutes
two minutes let's go I
I've heard a rumor
that She-Hulk and Daredevil sleep with
each other and I'm very curious to see
that like really like I really I really
am I really am I do believe Daredevil
will be in this video or episode I don't
see why they would tease us with the the
helmet in the last episode
like really
uh is Dr Doom going to be the Fantastic
Four movie that's a
I don't know
that's a that's a big question you know
dude
uh I'm making sure I got it up here for
those wondering uh or for those who
weren't here I did kind of fix it
to where I can randomly show parts
randomly show parts now
I think I figured out
how to get past it
you think I look like Pedro Pascal Ryan
I am Spanish you can't tell
but my mom on my mom's side
um part Mexican
so
La Lisa big lump reacts love love Lisa
love her in the in pink venom and shut
down those two videos that came out
recently with their comeback is
yeah and then in lalisa in that one and
then in the money performance video
yep
yeah not much is known about the
Fantastic Four movie right now we just
got the two writers
um
but uh
and we know the director and that's
about it that's about all we know okay
um
let's see if it's out
oh thank you young Skywalker I
appreciate that
just Gin Gin is a bridesmaid in a
friend's wedding
stressful event compounded by uniquely
She-Hulk issues okay
cool okay we ready we're gonna start
this in five four
three
two
one
okay so I can either show a timer or I
can show
I can show like the episode and I think
I'm gonna choose to show the episode
like this
I need to put it a little lower because
I don't want to get copyrighted I don't
want the stream to get copyrighted
hey Christian Santos
yeah oh your dad's Mexican nice yeah my
grandparents are from Mexico on my mom
said
I know I look super wet
yeah Leon hey thanks for Super Chat also
sorry guys I'm reading super chats I'm
not saying thank you for the super chats
thank you so much all the super chats
really appreciate that I really
appreciate them all
um sorry okay so we are in the opening
Marvel intro here I actually need to
switch these screens hold on give me let
me let me figure out how this works I
need this to be over here I need my
stream labs to be over here the problem
is my feed's over here but uh
I think okay I'll do this hold on I'll
put this here
and then I'll put this here
there we go
and then on the other side I'll do the
no because then I can't show
I'll figure this out give me a second
I'll figure this out
all right I'm working on it I promise
there we go
okay
I still can't do it that way that
doesn't make sense ah boss
okay I'll just do it this way
that's shulky that's funny
okay got it now they're just talking
they're just talking
no you're She-Hulk which is why she
asked you to be a bridesmaid so She-Hulk
would arrive at her wedding it's obvious
Nikki's so funny
fair fair that is how weddings always
are yes
I have not seen all of us are dead
tauren I have not I'm feeling this music
though
she's here
oh she's stealing the Thunder of the
wedding
oh she pissed
she's taking all the attention
oh she wants her to be Jin not Hulk
oh that's not the wedding
huh
surely is big
I thought jyn would be happy
that's funny so she didn't want to show
up as just Jen because
yeah I don't know about Daredevil in
this episode now y'all uh
maybe they're trying to trick Us by
saying it's a self-contained episode
oh she's just Jen now
who is Jonathan
Jonathan is literally the best so who is
he
okay
back
Mr immortal
are they really throwing Mr
moral mortal Mr Immortal in there like
this
are they I really hope this episode
doesn't make a joke of a lot of
characters that's kind of something I'm
worried about
just so everyone can see this is what he
looks like we're like
that's Mr Immortal in the MCU now
dang
so who is he married to
and you wear red pajamas
huh
I kind of die
so he he he faked his death
he faked his death to
to get out of a marriage
Nikki is wow Nicki is like
oh he uh he just jumped out the window
to kill himself
oh my gosh they landed on the ground
well he jumped up Mr immortal
oh he landed on a security car
well there you go there's Mr immortal
so crazy to just randomly threw them in
there like that
as you saw I now have super powers which
is nuts
oh my gosh this is such like a caddy a
caddy thing happening right now
but I'm a big shot lawyer oh no are you
dating anybody no oh it's okay you'll
find somebody
oh look who it is
Titania's here
oh this is kind of funny
this is some really like
he show he he he's they're really show
like this is funny this is like very
catty and sneaky
and now I'm assuming a guy's about to
pop up and uh say say hi to her
who's this guy
I like this guy already
Josh look it's Josh guys
that
huh
would I like that guy where did oh
hmm
oh this guy's back
was is she was he married to all of
these women
and that guy
oh my gosh
wow good what I got Mr Immortal wow
oh Mr Anderson calling me more
Akshay Kumar thank you for subscribing
intelligencia the one for hateful man
babies
his body regenerates
so he
said this guy was married to all of
these women and faked his death to get
out of the marriage with all of them are
you kidding me right now
if I live to be uh and I will
don't touch me
we're gonna have to pay
why are you smiling it's fun wow
okay back at the wedding
what a
horrible dress
oh no those are those dresses kind of
suck
I'm sorry
I just I really think they're terrible
video games are sports now that's funny
oh my gosh
they're just really really screwing with
her this is really stupid
there it's not gonna be that easy
um
enchantable Hulk that's their cousin
right
chat or whatever his name is
nice
oh is she getting drunk and dancing now
yep she's getting drunk and doing a
bunch of dancing oh yep cash bar
no hey what's up Michelle how's it going
oh my gosh and Nikki's like freaking
she is taking care of all the people
that freaking
Mr Immortal screwed over that's
hilarious
wow that's funny
oh Darkness under the wind that's a good
point maybe she might be uh kidnapped
real quick
oh my gosh interpretable
hey Jericho have a have a
have a good one this is a
so did they get money from all the
people that
is she talking to Bruce
dang it nope
so is Josh gonna kidnap her
is Josh gonna kidnap her
Josh and Son oh my gosh what's up Bryce
dude this guy's gonna kidnap her
he's gonna kidnap her I'm trying to
this guy's gonna kidnap her
great job lowering the law
dude I'm really really strong
Hershey hoax hair look does look better
oh
dude this guy's gonna kidnapper and
would be so pissed because he seems like
a genuinely good dude
but he's gonna he's gonna turn out to be
like a villain or some crap and it's
gonna be like every guy I like is a
douchebag or a villain or something like
that
oh no
no why is the tape oh and titana just
punched her in the face
oof
all right here it comes
I don't get over anything oh how do
people not see her shoving her down
right now
I don't think she can take it like that
[Laughter]
punched missed and fell on the ground
interesting
green up
oh oh is she not gonna be able to do it
oh she is doing it nope she can't do it
give me a second
does she kind of look like Titania has
green in her eyes
oh
there we go
oh nice
she's gonna ruin the she is like
smashing that hard
we got a wedding fight
oh
Titania's actually putting up a good
fight against her
until that happened oh my gosh to the
Electric Slide that's hilarious
good we're in her wedding
she was she sucked anyways should not
have been her bridesmaid
now of course everyone's taking pictures
and
oh my gosh she slipped on eyes and did
she get knocked out unconscious
nope oh no that's not a good look
she chipped some teeth my veneers
oh that's not good
oh
oh and that her
cousin's gonna be pissed oh what up
that's her wedding dress
what a horrible wedding dress
oh she's like super drunk
oh
huge poops
that was a horrible wedding dress and we
are not seeing Daredevil okay
oh
she's married I thought they were gonna
get together
do you have children
oh Mallory does not want people to know
too much
[ __ ] She-Hulk
okay this is weird
is this is Intelligentsia wow
because intelligence is like a criminal
organization in comics
so
does she does she work for intelligencia
is that what's Happening Here
she told her
I think Mallory might be a villain she
is a villain in the comics
oh she left her a voicemail I'm very
concerned that this Josh guy is gonna
be working he he's something from
Intelligentsia
well someone is
macro blood level is this the next phase
of the plan ready to go Hulk King okay
here we go we're fine oh there's the
broken thing all right we're finally
getting we're finally getting something
show us something
oh they've got something better to stab
her with this time
is there a post-credit scene
but
what happened no there we go
no post credit scene
I'm I'm
kind of starting to think like why
like why why why
like I don't know what was the point of
that episode
kind of entertaining at some points
it was very short
um
no
no Daredevil which I I really thought it
was going to be in this so what we have
three episodes left
I am a scroll
I won't say your name because it'll get
me
I I think Daredevil's only in one
episode I think they confirmed he's only
in one episode
they did introduce Mr Immortal from the
comics but like he was like nothing
which is so weird
yeah I know but I know there was a
report that Daredevil would appear in
three episodes but I think Charlie Cox
came out and said that he was only in
one maybe he's trolling
yeah this I mean this like it had some
cool parts to it but I'm starting like
there I'm starting
I don't know I'm just like where's the
they keep teasing us with like a big
connection and I'm not
getting it like where's the villain it's
clearly not Titania right there's
clearly something bigger but we're six
episodes in and we have
zero idea
I mean
I need a villain
it's just like uh what is happening you
know
uh it needs to end really strong
it needs to end really strong I mean
they're saving Daredevil for the end I
know
um
and like I want to appreciate the
episode for what it was
but it was kind of just there it kind of
just exists you know what I mean like
there's some good parts to it don't get
me wrong I laughed
um but like
I just keep questioning like
like why why did we just see that
episode you know what I mean
um
I feel like it's not progressing in a
good way like I feel like like I feel
like there's just like no progression
this episode like whatsoever
and like I get the pun of like a wedding
being inconvenient so the wedding
episode is inconvenient just like a
wedding would actually be
um
huh yeah I'm I'm curious
they did Jen did warn us you know so
yeah see I'm I'm with you Harmon like
I'm I'm
trying to think of like the episode like
trying to take it in for what it was but
to me it was kind of pointless uh
not gonna lie
uh there was a report that there will be
some other hoax in Captain America New
World Order
DJ wavd makes a good point Daredevil's
getting an eight 18 episode 16 episode
show
16. 18. can't remember
um
we're gonna get a lot of Daredevil
Mr Anderson the show is far closer to a
network Prime Time comedy about a hero
than it is Marvel Comics action
adventure yeah for sure for sure
and that's what I mean by like I'm
trying to take it in for what it is
right and I think there's like I think
there's an issue here
is I think it's meant to be that way Mr
Anderson
I think it's meant to be that's what I
thought 18 episodes that's what I
thought it
it's meant they want it to be like a
network Prime Time comedy show but the
fact of the matter is it's still a
Marvel show
with a Marvel character who is a big
character in the comics
so there's like a fight here
I feel like
I just need something more I'm not even
saying that like what we're seeing is
like really bad I just feel like I I
need something more
like I'm not excited anymore to watch
the show like I wasn't really excited
about that episode it was entertaining
at some point parts
uh
and I like She-Hulk and I and I like
Tatiana manslani I do I really do I'm
rooting for the show I am rooting for
the show I really am
um
and I'm not like yeah it's disappointing
Daredevil wasn't in this this episode
but I'm not like you know
if I felt like if the episode was better
I wouldn't have been so disappointed you
know what I mean but
but this was a very filler episode to me
that's what I'm disappointed in I think
that that this episode was such a filler
like
like let me go back through it
real quick I want to see something
it's like it's literally like the
wedding
the wedding and then Mr Immortal which
I'm really like I don't like that they
just kind of like threw them in there
right
and then intelligencia was like the
the
thing
and uh
like the whole story with Mr Immortal
was pointless
I don't think that'll pop up again I
literally think it was just this this
filler right it was kind of funny how
Nikki was like helping you know all of
his spouses get things because he's such
a wimp essentially like
but like relevance
like the only big thing that kind of
happened was
besides that it was you know she beat up
Titania in like a 20-second fight
I should deal with some catty women
that's true Jeff likes K-pop
we still have uh Daredevil Frogman and a
mill at Meditation Retreat hopefully the
next three episodes are hopefully they
give us the filler right before they're
really good episodes right
Josh does give bad vibes Jocelyn like I
like him but I am you know he's almost
too good right where it's like it freaks
you out and she's kind of like okay
what's wrong with you right like what's
your secret you're too good
hmm
I gotta say I think uh
like this I definitely think this is my
least favorite episode
I actually really enjoyed like the first
four episodes
um
I think what I'm missing is one like an
actual like main antagonist of the show
right like
or like like a driving point of the show
because there's not a lot of continuity
there's not a lot of stories that like
continue like Mr Anderson said like if
it's like a sitcom I'm thinking of like
the Big Bang Theory right that's a show
that I love there's always like a
driving force like sometimes it's the
relationship between like Leonard and
Penny you know sometimes it's you know
other thing it's just like there's
there's not like a clear like direction
that it's going it's just kind of
existing it's almost like Seinfeld like
there's no story it's just random every
single episode
but it's not Seinfeld you know so it's
like
I'm rooting for the show I'm rooting for
the show I'm hoping the last three
episodes are good I think it started off
you know pretty strong
um I think this
I think the first and the fourth episode
so far are my favorites
so yeah
JG the show's no motivation or direction
there's no middle I feel like we're
still in the beginning that's kind of a
that's kind of how I feel
uh I
yeah I mean I want Mr Anderson I agree
with you like I wanted like I wanted
She-Hulk to like be a Hulk
right like
I I wanted
She-Hulk I wanted the She-Hulk that I
know from the comics and I get part of
it right because in the comic she she's
funny she sleeps around and stuff you
know she's loud she gets kicked out of
you know the Avengers place and
everything like that I mean
that's stuff we're kind of seeing right
um
but I feel like
I don't know I feel like it's it it it
it's not taking us anywhere as of late I
really like the first four episodes well
I like to I liked one two and four I
can't remember if it was two or three
that I didn't like
but yeah I think the first and the
fourth one were the best ones that we
got so far unfortunately
who watched Andor I really like the
first few episodes of Andor
I really really did uh maybe we
shouldn't talk about it because spoilers
so
I don't know yeah I guess I was kind of
expecting uh
I'm not like super disappointed like
Daredevil because this is she-hulk's
show right like
this is She-Hulk show
uh so the fact that he didn't show up is
disappointing but it wouldn't like ruin
the episode for me what ruined the
episode was the episode like I just uh I
kind of feel like it was pointless and I
just didn't get much from it like just
to be honest right I know I usually like
a lot of Marvel stuff but to me it's
just uh
this didn't really deliver and the last
episode didn't for me either and I I
just really
I'm so weirded out about how they just
threw Mr Immortal in there you know I'm
just like so weirded out by that
uh I mean it's not like he's a super
huge you know guy but
he led the
what was the X-Men team
oh it was like a
what was the X-Men team
Great Lakes X-Men team
so it's not like you know what I mean
and like he's like a younger guy like
I'm looking at you know comic pictures I
mean he's a young guy too you know
so it's really interesting that
hmm
interesting I'm kind of
yeah I I'm
concerned uh
I I'm kind of concerned that they just
threw him in like that as like a
nonchalant character
it's the only way I can put that
right the best way but I guess yeah I do
kind of feel like it was a
I I kind of I kind of think it was a
waste of an episode
yeah I've seen some people say it now
too there you go
um I don't know about a red Hulk cameo
is it uh
is his name Lucas the guy from Baywatch
that she went on a date with and then
saw it the firm I think he's supposed to
be the bad guy
I really do think that I do Muhammad I
I think they wasted Mr Immortal I'm I'm
I'm very shocked with
what they decided to do
I'm not even disappointed like the fact
that Daredevil wasn't in this episode
does not affect how I feel uh
about the episode like
you know I'm not like I hate this
episode because Daredevil wasn't in it I
just I don't know the episode didn't do
anything for me
I want smashing I want
you know I want She-Hulk I want She-Hulk
I get this episode like a downfall I'm
not sure what you mean by that
well and that's what I was saying Mr
Anderson like I totally get it like I
totally get that this demographic for
this isn't necessarily tailored towards
me it's tailored you know
I think towards women
I could totally get that right
but you're right they are they're trying
to like I said it's still a Marvel show
it's still a Marvel show you know what
I'm saying like it's still a Marvel show
and I actually I just think writing is
not so well
it's not doing so well because like
I thought some of the writing for Miss
Marvel was bad
like I did
I
and I see a little bit of that now I
thought the first four episodes of this
were good
I do want her to to do more Hulk
smashing
Tom I agree I'm waiting I'm willing to
see I hope the show ends well you know
what I'm saying
yeah Armin I'm hoping Frogman isn't uh
just a throwaway
I really hope
and they're really short which you know
what I mean like they're really short
episodes
uh talio
um
I'm waiting to see how it ends I do
people do when we talk about like rating
shows like if we like them or not do we
include what if
I really didn't like winter
um actually
perfect example I think I've made it
pretty clear that I really didn't like
what if
I felt like I was watching what if this
episode that's how I felt I was just
kind of like
but
I like She-Hulk and Tatiana manslane so
this is uh I'm conflicted because I'm
really rooting for her I'm really
rooting for the character I'm really
rooting for the show I am you know what
I mean this doesn't like put me out of
the show
um
disappointed that it wasn't uh
better like
the story wasn't better
that's all
uh so who do we think
is the let me look at something real
fast
oh I'm tired let's go over there
oh
you know what's interesting is
um
there's some there's a connection
between intelligencia and Dr Doom
he like I think he like betrays the uh
betrays like intelligencia
who is
who is the leader of intelligence yeah
do we know that
oh
Modoc
and he's coming in quantumania
okay
yeah I think we need uh
yeah I'm with you Colin like I said like
the writing for me has been a little
subpar recently
did y'all hear the rumor that Ryan
Gosling might play Doctor Doom
how do we feel about that
it is very random sidhan yeah and that's
yeah like I said it's almost like
Seinfeld
but but but it's not Seinfeld right
because nothing will ever be Seinfeld
it's like there's no Rhyme or Reason to
some episodes
uh Jeff likes K-pop La is not too far
from San Francisco no did you say
something else that I missed here
I'm not sure what your
kind of talking about
I think Gosling would be awesome true
too you know I I really do think Ryan
Gosling as Dr Doom would be crazy cool I
I do know that he's talked with Marvel
Studios
but Marvel Studios talks to a lot of
people about a lot of different roles
until they find that perfect role for
them right that's the deal which is
really cool and sometimes they might not
ever find that role
uh Comics I suppose I'm back I'm
agreeing with you
thanks for the Super Chat uh yeah this
to me this is the worst episode and I'm
really disappointed that it wasn't
that it was at the the caliber that it
was
yeah
you heard nikolaj Coster Waldo was
playing Dr Jim I have no idea what that
is
yeah yeah I just looked it up uh got to
11. uh I I couldn't remember who the
leader or who the actual leader of
intelligencia was uh but yeah I saw
Modoc and the leader
um there is a connection to Dr Doom
there I'm pretty sure if memory serves
me right that they that that that he
betrays them in some type of way
did the web uh Danny Bella thinks the
Super Chat I was actually going to look
that up right now hold on
because uh
it says Hulk King
is the next phase of the plan ready to
go Hulk King I can't screenshot and zoom
in on this but uh
I wouldn't be surprised if it was the
leader I I really I really
I wouldn't at this point in time
so look at like this is like footage of
the
I'm looking at it right here oh let me
do this I can do this now
I can do this now I figured it out
um
this is like footage of them right here
of gin and uh
yeah this is footage of them
at the table so they've got cameras like
everywhere
trying to see if I can like find any
Easter eggs or something I just see
macro blood count
uh I'm never gonna be able to read
what's on the paper
what is that saying what does that say
go back
ah dang it too far back
what's it say on the microscope
anti-mold
okay I don't know what that means I'm
not a scientist
it's a big old freaking needle
I mean
yeah let's go through
intelligencia we are the web use this
form create a new post
uh hold on let me get rid of these
subtitles so I can see more of the
screen
oh all it says is in cancel She-Hulk
She-Hulk should be canceled she
discriminates against anyone who doesn't
share her pathetic man-hating
[Music]
or like why is it so dark I can barely
read it
oh no go back
okay
She-Hulk sucks that's funny
Bigfoot Bitcoin USA exercise protein
UFOs yes that's what all of us men care
about of course
I actually do care about UFOs so jokes
on y'all
okay what do we have here
oh everything that I just freaking read
pretty much so I squinted and did a lot
of that for nothing
all right what do we have here
slash cars is that guy's username
slash Heroes is that guy's username I'm
this is really generic someone shoot
She-Hulk
wow that's
what are the when you a Hulk but you're
still dumb once equality still wants you
to pay for dinner wears yoga pants match
when you look guilty of dressing like a
man
some hate right there
how do we SWAT She-Hulk
eight reasons she hulks she She-Hulk
needs to die that's
a lot
it's pretty dark
how do we kill She-Hulk does anyone know
how we can kill her it's time to do
something all ideas and discussions
welcome jeez 284 comments
wait it's just said something else
hold on
no hold on
[Music]
She-Hulk isn't even that strong If She
Hulk and the real Hulk got into a fight
the Hulk would totally kick her butt no
questions asked
I don't know what I'd even do if I saw
them fighting though LOL I might have to
get in the ring with them and beat up
She-Hulk she's not even strong
um
interesting interesting interesting okay
intelligencia is just an edgy Reddit
that's pretty funny Spider-Man
I think Mallory might be kind of bad
she is bad in the comics
Nokia
yeah I'm not seeing anything here
um
there's nothing I can really make out
here
yeah I'm definitely thinking that uh
Mallory is bad
foreign
am I still alive
hit something on streamlabs
I didn't do it
except I obviously did it
hmm
it's not Daredevil in time you're right
about that ritwick and what is up
another member in the chat
um
oh red Slayer Lewis is that you're
talking about rensslayer I liked
rensslayer
I'm excited to see her return
um
yeah I mean
this show is going to lead to itself
being destroyed
uh Debbie Davey Cabral that's a good
question I wonder if like uh
if the needle is like made out of
vibranium or something like that you
know
Luke de Bruin I see your comment Mr
Anderson but I don't see Luke's let's
find it
I'm not finding it
now I see it uh
Daredevil clip this show's last post
credit scene Dalo no thank you for the
that uh super chat but no nothing of
Daredevil
uh Daredevil
foreign
Val and Kingpin
uh could be behind this
but what is this is his name Lucas hold
on
uh She-Hulk cast
Todd that's his name Todd
I think it's Todd that's gonna be the
bad guy right
here let me pull it up on the screen
it's the Baywatch guy
this guy
he's gonna be the bad guy I believe
whoops
Baywatch guy
I think uh
yeah I don't know who Hulk Keen is
that's Hulk King is it that's not like a
to my knowledge that's not a comic book
character I mean we've had Hulk be a
king before but that like in the planet
Hulk uh World War Hulk storyline you
know
um
yeah uh Luke debrun uh I've said my
thoughts about this a lot I liked it in
the beginning uh this episode was
uh and I I hope it I hope it gets better
you know
so right now I'm thinking I'm thinking
this guy
I don't know who he could be I don't
know what villain he could be because we
obviously yeah this is the Baywatch guy
um
we obviously know that he's not the
leader because we already know who's
going to be the leader maybe he works
for the leader
uh you know at first I thought it could
be Kingpin uh
needing the Hulk serum to restore his
eye because uh Echo shot him in the eye
um
I'm kind of veering away from that uh
there was of course always the and
there's still of course is the
possibility that it could be Val
Valentina de Allegro Fontaine or
Valentina Allegre de Fontaine
um
and you know if she was working for
Thunderbolt Ross we know Thunderbolt
Ross you know Hulk's here we know all
the connections there that could be
something
um
I I mean just makes sense to be the
leader and it's probably Todd working
for the leader remember he called her a
specimen and all this stuff and uh
then he showed up again randomly we know
like we know Todd's not done because he
showed up and the last episode not the
one we just watched episode five
remember he showed up at the firm that
does that doesn't just happen right that
was very intentional
so Todd is something
and I don't think he's a hero
um
and he mentioned vibranium before so
that needle could be made out of
vibranium to stab She-Hulk
and uh get her blood for the leader
and then the leader employed this guy
and The Wrecking Crew he might have been
one of those people trying trying to no
we saw other people but he could be the
boss and then the leader could be his
boss
so
yeah
you think the kingpins over you think
kingpin's over The Wrecking Crew
Maybe
those guys were kind of stupid like uh
well oh gosh
what was the what were the guys called
the Bros
rent a bro move a bro what what were
they called in uh
Hawkeye
I don't remember their name
yeah so Mallory like
Mallory's not like a a big villain in
the comics she's just like
I think she's more of a workplace rival
I'll have to like uh read up on it again
she leads something against her but I
know they make up eventually so she's
not like a big villain I don't think
Mallory is like a super huge villain
tracksuit Mafia trust a bro that's what
it was Solace thank you
rent a bro trust a bro there we go there
we go there we go anyway I knew they
were the tracksuit Mafia but there was
the the fake name like trust the Bro
moving company something like that
yeah uh I believe there's Nine episodes
there was supposed to be ten but they
cut one I think there might be ten but I
think it's nine
uh I mean they could just recast William
Hurt You know it is sad that he died in
real life but uh
but I mean
they can recast they can see GI you know
yeah the traction Mafia was great I
thought that was uh it was great and it
was it was fun
um
the question is who is behind
intelligencia
who is behind intelligence here
foreign
look if you like the episode I'm happy
for you I really am
if you didn't I relate I didn't
personally like this episode
but I would never tell anybody they're
wrong for liking this episode I'm
actually happy for the people who liked
this episode
critwick Dr Michael morbius yeah
you know what I I there's a lot of
possibilities who it could be right now
like Modoc is gonna be in
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania I'm
just getting real I'm getting really
tired if I have to remember the name of
Ant-Man 3 and it takes a little
while
um modoc's going to be in quantumania
there's a connection there he's in
charge of Intelligentsia in the comics
uh
but the leader makes the leader has a
lot of connections as well because he's
coming back in Captain America New World
Order
and
and Todd our Baywatch bruh
he's
maybe like maybe we can still have like
Modoc and leader working together they
make intelligencia Todd runs
intelligencia for them
he employed The Wrecking Crew there's a
lot of layers
um
I don't think it's Kingpin
but at the same time Daredevil is going
to come in why would Daredevil come in I
mean I guess because you know the whole
lawyer thing
Matt Murdoch I mean that makes sense
there's a lot of things
I think
Richie Stacks it's Vanessa kingpin's
wife
who's Vanessa
like in what
like what do you like I didn't she's not
in the show is she
am I missing a comment here I
am not seeing it
I'm looking for the cone I'm fine
okay you guys keep talking about Vanessa
but like where was she in the show
that's my question
was the was the bride Vanessa
I I have to agree I don't even feel like
this is a lawyer show
guys I know who Vanessa is but who is
she in in the in the
in the episode
is uh was she
was she the bride that's my question I
don't I don't remember
no her name was Lulu
where are you guys getting Vanessa from
I'm so confused was Vanessa in this [ __ ]
why why do we keep mentioning Vanessa
someone explain
America explained
Todd's not frog man we know who Frogman
is
we know who Frogman is
oh thank you Mr Anderson I was everyone
kept saying Vanessa I'm like dude I know
who Vanessa is where was she in the show
okay okay okay disregard but sorry
that's my but I'm tired it's it's very
late
I don't Talk's not fraud man we know the
actor who plays frogman
actually met him at the launch a bit of
time I met the guy
um
yeah look I don't care
um that Daredevil wasn't in this episode
I do think it's kind of jacked that uh
they teased us last episode
but but uh didn't didn't put us didn't
put him in this episode
um
kind of kind of jacked up but uh you
know that that's not like that's not why
I didn't like the episode uh
I just didn't
I don't know I just don't like the
episode
um
let me look this up
huh
uh I don't think I don't know of anyone
to be Mr immortal's son Barton Magnus
bags
um
not to my knowledge and Comics Eros
Ramos what are my thoughts on Endor
really like the I've seen four episodes
and uh I really liked them
I really really did I I enjoy that so
far I enjoy Andor so far
I I did think this episode was kind of
nothing
yep
yep yep
yeah no I really enjoyed indoor
that's funny people are complaining
about Daredevil but you guys remember
what Kevin feige did with Ralph Ralph
boner troll so this is good in my
opinion
yeah I mean I'm not even like I think
it's kind of funny and messed up at the
same time that they teased Daredevil
last episode and didn't put him in this
episode
um
but that's not what
made me not like this episode it was
just a bad episode to me
uh no I have not seen Better Call Saul
nope not even one episode I
uh
yeah uh it's just the writing of this
episode uh and
the last episode to me we're off not
very good to me
um
and writing and direction are major
parts of if uh
the show is good a movie's good
look if you like the episode great I
didn't personally like it
um
like that's a great way to put it this
was just an episode
yeah I mean really uh
I mean there were some funny parts there
were some entertaining Parts I'm not
like wow I hate this episode so much I
uh I just didn't get much from it
and the reason I didn't get much from it
is because it still has yet to progress
this this whatever She-Hulk is whatever
it's supposed to be it's not progressing
right it it's we're done with the the
sixth episode we don't have a villain in
a nine episode series
this was kind of my
issue with uh Miss Marvel towards the
end like the writing got a little sloppy
to me
yeah I mean but there were some
interesting Parts uh like I just I'm so
weirded out that they just threw in Mr
immortal like that I'm just so weirded
out I really am it threw me off
it threw me off
like they and I feel like they just
threw them away like they just threw uh
the leader of the Great Lakes Avengers
away you know like
oh oh I loved Moon Knight too Mr
Anderson loved Moon Knight
I loved like everything about midnight
but yeah like to me it was just like you
know like what I saw was fine
I didn't hate anything
about it I just like we're
we just ended the sixth episode and and
we're still like
what's the where is this going what's
the point right and not like in a good
way
like
not like they've been like we've been
wondering this whole entire time because
of certain events it's just kind of like
nothing has happened and still nothing
has happened so I'm just kind of like
uh I don't know
not sure not sure I have hopes for the
show like I've been saying
I like
Tatiana and saloni I like the character
She-Hulk a lot
um
I hope it ends well
yeah ritwick that's kind of how I feel
right now it's like they're not going to
introduce like the big villain until the
end and then it's like gonna be rushed
and I'm just like oh especially because
these are 30 minute episodes
I don't even think this is like a lawyer
show though some people are saying like
you know it's a lawyer show we haven't
seen that much like if you watch a
normal like law show like okay I just
watched uh
extraordinary attorney Wu it's a K drama
about an autistic lawyer they like dive
into law and like they talk like it's
all about trials and stuff and a lot of
trial law shows are like that this isn't
like that
Maybe
the last episode kind of did it
but yeah
I know it's meant to be like a sitcom
but I kind of mentioned this before
where it's like there still are a lot of
driving forces and sitcoms
um I used Big Bang Theory as an example
and like say friends like there's
there's always like something driving a
certain story where it's like it's it's
typically relationships like Leonard and
Penny right and then you have like
Howard and and Bernie and you know
there's just always something right uh
friends it's like Ross and Rachel Monica
and Chandler like there's always
something that's like you know you're
you're moving forward you're progressing
like I don't feel that with She-Hulk
hmm
yeah you know I don't I don't feel like
it's a larger show
but anyways all right guys it's time to
wrap up because I have work to do and I
have sleep to get and
um you know I'm holding out
for the last few episodes I hope it ends
well I still think it's redeemable like
I said I felt like it started off really
well but uh
I I think
I think the last two episodes were the
were no yes maybe I don't know I I think
I didn't like episode three or something
like that
um
but this episode was the worst by far um
and I feel like we haven't gone anywhere
so hopefully
um
I I hope
I hope it ends strong very strongly
um as I told you guys before
um if you like music and you like K-pop
I started a channel
I will put that in the chat
uh Mr Anderson has a channel as well you
can follow him
he will put that in the chat and if
you're not subbed and you want to
subscribe to my channel to talk about
Marvel content let's do that
um
I I see a few comments here but I I feel
like I I missed a few comments to to
actually comment
um but hey who knows what the story is
going to go perhaps it's amazing right
uh this was the worst episode for me but
it doesn't
to cheer me from having hope for the
show I I like the beginning and I like
She-Hulk and I hope the I hope the
I hope they do her justice like She-Hulk
really is a good character like really
like from the comics Great Character
and funny character the comedy is kind
of a Miss for me in this show like I
laugh sometimes but um
some of the comedy isn't really there
for me but hey I'm not the demographic
so um if you liked this episode good I'm
glad I would never take that away from
you I would you know never let my
opinion
I hope my opinion wouldn't make you
change your opinion so uh
I
I'm happy for everyone who's enjoying
this episode and I hope it or this
series I've enjoyed the series uh I just
thought this episode was a little weak
so
uh thank you to everybody for coming out
thank you to Mr Anderson of course for
being the best mod out there uh getting
the job done be sure to subscribe this
channel for his content
um I'll plug my K-pop channel one more
time and uh yeah look out for some
videos tomorrow
um I have an extremely stressful and
busy day tomorrow
I don't even know if I'll upload a video
but I will try I'll try to get the
She-Hulk uh She-Hulk video out there if
not another video out there I got a lot
of other ones up in the
up in my repertoire
um
let's see we'll see we'll see um
I'm waiting to see
I'm waiting to see how this
this plays out uh for I saw some people
asking about K-pop it's not just gonna
be K-pop I'm gonna do normal music as
well just a lot of Kpop stuff's been
happening lately but uh yeah anyways
um oh sorry rocket sorry go to sleep
stay asleep
um we'll be back next week we'll be back
next week for episode seven maybe
Daredevil maybe Frogman I you know I
definitely thought uh
I thought this was gonna be the
Daredevil episode but hey that's Marvel
salt they teased Daredevil the last
episode so we'll see I feel like there
is something
big that could happen at the end that
they're just for some reason waiting for
I don't know why
really really I really don't know why
but we'll see
um but all right I will catch you all
next week thank you to everybody uh for
showing up for this live stream really
appreciate it thanks for all the super
chats the regular chats and of course
the people who are just watching uh hope
you enjoyed it
um and we will catch you all next week
love you all in every universe